(audience clapping)
Ladies and gentlemen,
the one the only, Patti LaBelle.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Thank you, hi honey.
How are you?
Damn, you look hot!
Oh, thank you, sweetie.
Thank you.
You remember we met about 15 years ago,
when you're were a baby.
You and your mom?
I think it was Johnny Carson.
Yes.
(indistinct)
Back in the day.
Hey girl!
I think
(indistinct)
it was in 1984.
1984?
Wow!
My God time flies.
Did you like doing the tonight show?
I loved doing The Tonight Show.
And he asked me back a few times.
You know, so I was very happy to do it every time I did it.
(audience laughing)
Every time.
I was too.
I loved doing The Tonight Show.
It was, I did it for the first time when I was seven.
And I kept going back and back.
I one time I brought him,
dishes with his name on it.
Because it was like.
Really?
In the Inquirer,
and all the rag mags that.
Oh.
This latest divorce was so bad.
She even took the dishes.
(audience laughing)
So I got him a bunch of dishes with his name on it.
Was like, "She is not gonna want them now."
(audience laughing)
Ha!
That was nice of you.
(laughing)
Very nice.
Yeah.
You know, I'm looking at you now,
and you really,
I mean just
the crisp white silk
and you're fabulous.
Like perfect hair.
And your style
Aw!
is so iconic.
And I was wondering if you
Thank you.
don't mind if we take a little look
at some of your greatest fashion moments?
Please look.
(clapping)
Cause I have to see 'em too.
Okay!
(chuckles) Go ahead.
Wow!
I love
this look.
Tell us about this.
This was,
of course LaBelle.
I can't really remember where we were there.
But that was truly Patti LaBelle.
And had some drag.
(laughs)
It's so cool.
And so like monochromatic
head to toe.
In the same material.
Yeah.
I really loved the color of this.
Here's another look
Thank you.
Actually.
Oh, this dress.
Oh yeah.
That was Tommy.
I did it with Pete Townshend, yeah!
And somebody else.
That was about a hundred years ago.
I don't remember everything,
but I remember that dress.
It was phenomenal.
Yeah.
That dress is like an architectural Marvel.
And then
Yeah.
Here's another look.
This was for a Mac makeup.
It was in Canada.
And I had my drag on.
And I did a show and it was fun.
You know.
Now I'm dressing down.
You know, COVID I'm like laid back a little bit.
(chuckles)
But I still like my drag.
The dress up is the best!
It really is.
And.
Another thing you dressed up for
was Dancing with the Stars.
And
Yeah.
I mean,
Yes!
How did you move those hips?
And your costumes?
Did you enjoy that?
Drew, the costume was about 40 pounds, each one.
It was a lot of weight.
But after that show
they gave me those dresses.
And I wore them on stage honey.
And I was weighed down, but I was all myself.
(chuckles)
Beautiful for you.
Beautiful, heavy dress.
It's funny how like in the moment,
I feel like I could endure anything,
for a fabulous moment.
And then like,
You're right.
After you're like, God these are heavy.
But in the moment I'm like
I can do anything for this.
Right, I can.
(chuckles)
Anything.
Now Patti,
you're such a prolific amazing chef and cook and,
Oh my gosh.
I mean, your business,
is like it's just the biggest thing in the world.
Did you,
(indistinct)
have any special things during the pandemic that you made?
Well, I made strained beans, Patti Labella
for my grand babies.
Because they like cheese,
and it's mozzarella cheese with strained beans,
tomato sauce with garlic and
they were good.
And I made that for them like once a week.
That's what I've been doing for the last year.
Making strained beans, Patti LaBella.
Making brisket, making stewed chicken,
making anything.
And I went home for a year.
So it's like cooking everything.
I am so excited to cook with you.
And
(woman chuckles)
I've been scouring.
I mean your, the way
that you've run your business at Walmart.
Which I've been working there for 10 years too.
So I
Whoa yeah!
I'm excited to be,
sister vendors.
At the world's largest retailer.
(woman chuckles)
And,
Thank you.
It's just,
but I've never seen anything like it.
You sell up to 36,000 pies,
a day!
Oh God.
That's a blessing from God.
Yeah, that's a blessing.
Well, I think it's a blessing.
And all Patti LaBelle,
and your cooking.
It's a testament to that as well.
I wanted to also ask
since it's Valentine's week.
And I've got my heart sign.
Are you doing anything for Valentine's day?
A Galentine's, a Valentine's, a Palentine's?
(audience laughing)
A Palentine, a Valentine.
I'm gonna, I'm not gonna cook.
You know for my family they'll be here.
And we're just going to have like a (indistinct)
This is about 10 people who've been here
for the last 10 months.
And nothing big on Valentine's day.
No, just cooking.
Yeah, I don't have any Valentine's day plans either, yet.
(audience laughing)
Yet, right.
(laughs)
Never...
But you will right?
I don't know you never know where the day
is gonna take you.
You never know boo!
You never (chuckles)
Thank you, good okay!
(both laughing)
(upbeat music)